ferris in houston texas hey ferris how's
it going
good how are y'all doing today good
what's your question for anthony
today uh so i and i just recently
graduated uh
2019 december and i have about
twenty thousand dollars in a student
loan debt that has been deferred i
haven't had to pay
one payment yet um and um
i recently in october i bought a car
um i make about 55
a year pre-tax 55 and
55 yeah um and the reason why i bought a
car is that because i got 72 months
interest free
and my car payment is only about 280 a
month
i was wondering um how if i should sell
my car now
anthony anthony's not sure how he feels
about this let's give him a minute hang
on first let's
let him think about it what in the world
man i hate hearing now i got 72
months interest free zero interest
you're still in debt
you're still in it it's not free money
ferris you're still in debt yeah
you're still in that fair what kind of
car did you buy
uh a toyota camry sxc you bought a
toyota camry what
a toyota camry it's an xse how much was
it how much did you pay for it
uh i put down 9 000 down payment
um i have about twenty thousand left on
it so your total debt is forty thousand
yes right now my total debt is about
forty thousand so let me get this
straight
before you got the car you had twenty
thousand dollars in debt
and you had nine thousand dollars cash
uh yeah and i also have about 17 or 18
000
in the stock market
okay ferris i'm gonna calm down bro
walking through the baby steps walking
through the baby we'll walk you through
the baby steps fairs and then i want you
to i i i need to interview you on my
show because i think a lot of young
people would love
your story all right so far here's what
i'm going to recommend man
here's what your income right now is 55
000
a year you owe 20 000 left in the car
all right so
here's what i want you to do right now
you need to put all you need to stop
everything you're doing
and you need to go um i'm going to give
you a free
year of ramsay plus okay so stay on the
line when we get off
kelly's going to give that to you and i
want you to watch all the classes
okay because i don't have enough time to
walk you through all the baby steps
but babysit number one is a thousand
dollars in your emergency fund the
number two is you're going to pay off
all of your debt using the debt snowball
the reason why
i'm kind of like if you're watching me
on youtube you see my facial expressions
and my hands going all over the place
and i know the producers bryce and
anthony calm down
and chrissie's like oh my lord anthony's
getting upset is because i'm hearing a
young man
you could have been debt-free bro you
could have been 100
debt free and you could have paid cash
for the car you're you're the young man
that i wish
i could have got a hold of you you know
three months ago before you purchased
the car because i would have said all
right cool let's get you a car
you got seventeen thousand dollars in
single stocks right now
right um and then you have
say it again it's all an apple it's all
in apple yeah so 17 000 in single stocks
you had 9 000 in
uh in cash so you're sitting at 28
000. well yes yeah about 28 about 27 000
right there so i'm like man listen um
let's pay off to twenty thousand dollars
in debt and then let's take the rest of
that go buy a cash card for right now
and then from there let's start working
your way up
to go ahead and get you into the toyota
camry into something a little bit more
nicer that you really want it
but right now we can't do that so
um i want you to go ahead and focus on
paying off
uh there's twenty thousand dollars in in
student loans you're gonna line your
debt
up from smallest to largest and you have
two options okay
um and i'm gonna treat you just like how
dave was here you have two options you
can sell the car
which i would do in your situation um or
because it is only worth it's less than
half of your your actual income
um you can just get very aggressive with
it and pay that car off
but if you go that route man i'm talking
about you need to go out there and get
you an extra job it's a nice car you
need to be driving for uber
you need to be delivering pizza i want
to see you debt free within the next six
months
bottom line okay okay and so um you can
sell your card
uh that would be great the the the
problem that you're gonna have from
there
is will you have the cash to go buy you
a used car
that's the problem so you're saying hey
anthony i can sell the car and get the
cash go buy a new car
i'm going that route if you're saying
anthony i can bust my butt within the
next six months to pay off all of my
debt
i'm cool with that too yeah the the
thing to remember too
as well ferris is it it's not free money
yeah don't make this a mistake again
when you get debt free like anthony told
you just
the next time someone says oh zero
percent interest for however long
it does not matter you're still in debt
it is still
buying something you cannot afford and
when you do that
you are taking steps backwards not steps
forward in america
it's not free it was just included
inside of your car
okay that's it